the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
let's look now at storyboard 25 panels a
and B most of the pathways we have
studied so far in 507 have been
catabolic that is the breakdown of
molecules usually with the objective or
producing energy rich molecules such as
ATP or reducing equivalents that
ultimately could be used for reductive
biosynthesis now we're going to turn to
anabolism or biosynthesis biosynthetic
pathways are going to require energy
input as well as reducing equivalents
overall biosynthesis is an endergonic
process looking at panel B you can see
that we're going to start with fatty
acid and lipid biosynthesis fatty acids
are made in the cytoplasm the
mitochondrion is going to play an
important role however we'll see just
how in a couple of minutes let me say a
couple of things about the mitochondrion
first asset Eelco a oxaloacetate and the
nadp+ NADPH pair as we've described
above cannot pass through the
mitochondrial membrane however malate
and citrate can in fact they can go in
either direction keep these points in
mind as we move ahead now let's look at
panel C we're going to break down fatty
acid biosynthesis into five steps the
first step involves getting a Setia
coenzyme a into the cytoplasm as I just
said Asset Eelco a cannot directly go
past the mitochondrial membrane to
overcome this problem nature
quote-unquote packages acetyl co a is
citrate which can easily traverse did by
the chondral membrane hence we put
acetyl co a into a molecule of citrate
bring citrate out into the cytoplasm and
then split off the acetyl co a once
again the second step involves
maintaining oxaloacetate balance we just
transported a molecule of citrate out of
the mitochondrial matrix
thus depleting the TCA cycle of one of
its important intermediates the levels
of all
TCA cycle intermediates are going to
drop including oxaloacetate now think
about what's happened to the citrate in
the cytoplasm it was split into
oxaloacetate and as
if we could send that oxaloacetate back
into the mitochondrion the TCA cycle
would be replenished once again step two
will show how oxaloacetate finds its way
back into the mitochondrial matrix the
third step in fatty acid biosynthesis
involves the synthesis of malonyl
coenzyme a this molecule is made by
putting a carbon dioxide molecule onto
the methyl carbon of acetyl co a using
acetyl coenzyme a carboxylase an enzyme
we looked at earlier in the carboxylase
module of 507 malonyl coenzyme a is the
actual precursor to all but two of the
carbons in the fat in the fatty acid
chain the fourth step in fatty acid
biosynthesis involves putting the
Millenial coenzyme a onto a very large
protein on the fatty acid synthase
complex this large protein is called AC
P or acyl carrier protein the fifth step
involves the actual reactions of the
fatty acid synthase sometimes called FAS
this is a large multi protein complex
these are the enzymes by which we're
going to see the stepwise addition of
two carbon units up until we get to the
formation of a 16 carbon long fatty acid
called palmitic acid palma de casa de
brie v8 'add 16 colon zero is the
default fatty acid length made by the
fatty acid synthase complex let's look
at panel D after the five step synthesis
of palmitic acid this C 16 fatty acid
can be elongated it can have double
bonds put into it and it can be branched
we are not going to be looking into
those reactions but we shall be looking
into the way that either 2 or 3 fatty
acids will be placed onto a glycerol
backbone in order to make either a
membrane lipid that is a diacylglycerol
phosphate or try a so glycerides tri so
glycerides are our primary storage form
of energy we're not going to be looking
into those reactions but we shall be
looking at the way that either 2 or 3
fatty acids can be placed onto a
glycerol backbone in order to make
either a membrane lipid that is a
diacylglycerol phosphate
a try acyl glycerides trials acyl
glycerides our primary swords forms of
energy I'm not going to be going over
another type of fatty acid biosynthesis
called poly key tag biosynthesis but
I'll encourage you to take a look at
this pathway in the book polyketide
biosynthesis is a very important source
of a host of biologically active lipids
let's look at panel II before we look at
a schematic of lipid biosynthesis I'd
like to introduce NADPH NADPH is going
to be the source of electrons that are
used for reductive biosynthesis NADPH is
identical to NADH with the exception of
the phosphate at the lower right of the
molecule as drawn in panel II this
phosphate is a molecular decoration
that's recognized by biosynthetic
enzymes that is enzymes that are looking
for a source of reducing equivalents
NADPH is the cofactor that provides
those reducing equivalents the hydride
shown in the blue ellipse at the top of
the molecule represents the reducing
equivalents that we're going to be used
in biosynthesis the two main pathways
that result in the production of NADPH
for biosynthesis are the pentose
phosphate pathway which I'm going to
deal with in a separate lecture and the
Mallik enzyme which I'm going to
introduce in a few minutes now turn to
panel F this schematic shows a high
level view of fatty acid biosynthesis I
think it's useful to put fatty acid
biosynthesis in the context of one of
our physiological scenarios the scenario
is eat sugar get fat put more
scientifically this scenario is going to
show how the sugar we eat can end up
being converted very efficiently into
fat I think that probably most of us
want to avoid getting fat but keep in
mind that converting sugar to fat is one
way of converting energy into a very
compact and mobile form let's start with
the glucose molecule over on the left of
the panel starting with step one follow
the horizontal hatched line to the right
the glucose passes through glycolysis
produces pyruvate pyruvate goes into the
mitochondrion and is converted to acetyl
co a once again the
following the hatched line asset ilka
way condenses with oxaloacetate this is
the citrate synthase reaction to form
citrate rather than progressing further
into the TCA cycle where it would lose
its carbons as carbon dioxide the
citrate at step 2 is exported by a
transporter out into the cytoplasm
step 3 is catalyzed by an enzyme called
ATP citrate lyase this enzyme splits the
citrate into acetyl co a which is what
we want and leaves a residue a molecule
of oxaloacetate I'm not going to go
through the mechanism of this enzyme but
I think it's worthwhile to look back at
storyboard 7 look at the citrate
synthase reaction and then imagine it
running backwards now it's not going to
be exactly the reverse reaction as drawn
but at this point in 507 you should be
able to look at the co substrates for
the reaction and be able to figure out
how ATP citrate lyase liberate the
oxaloacetate residue I'm going to come
back to the oxaloacetate which is
labeled by a star in a few minutes keep
in mind that we have to find a way to
return oxaloacetate to the mitochondrial
matrix or else we won't have enough
oxaloacetate to enable the next molecule
of citrate to be formed from an incoming
acetyl coenzyme a at Step five we have
acetyl coenzyme a in the cytoplasm where
we want it for a fatty acid biosynthesis
but we can also do other things with
this molecule in the last lecture for
example I talked about ketone body
formation so look at the vertical arrow
that is the one going up you can see we
can produce hmg-coa hydroxymethyl
gluteal coenzyme a which as I said in
the last lecture is a biosynthetic
precursor to for example cholesterol as
well as ketone bodies then follow the
arrows through step 5 a to the
deposition of cholesterol into the
plasma membrane keep in mind cholesterol
is a plasticizer of the membrane
therefore it's an essential molecule now
let's go back and pick up the acetyl co
a as it progresses through the fatty
acid synthase or if FAS reactions of 5b
acetic away is
built up in eight steps to form the 16
carbon fatty acid palmitate following
the upward arrow palmitate can go on to
form a phospholipid which will become an
integral part of the membrane or it can
go horizontally to the left to form a
triglyceride which will become embedded
in a lipid globule where can serve as a
storage depot for energy so at this
point through the series of reactions
numbered 5a and 5b we've made the
membrane plasticizer cholesterol
phospholipids which are the main
structural elements of a biological
membrane and a tri atlas ride which is
our principal energy storage molecule
now let's go back to the asterisk
oxaloacetate at step 3
this orphaned molecule of oxaloacetate
has to be able to get back into the
mitochondrion there are two pathways by
which this can happen for a and for B
oxaloacetate is a ketone it can be
reduced by NADH to form the alcohol
malate this is the reverse of the
reaction that we're used to seeing in
the TCA cycle nevertheless this is
indeed the thermodynamically favorable
direction for this reaction the malate
dehydrogenase enzyme used here is
closely related to the one that's in the
mitochondrial matrix keep in mind
however that this is the cytoplasmic
version of the enzyme I mentioned
earlier that malate can go in either
direction across the mitochondrial
membrane in this case path for a malate
goes into the mitochondria becomes part
of the mitochondrial malate pool and
then the mitochondrial malate
dehydrogenase will convert it to
oxaloacetate and thus we have restored
the molecule of oxaloacetate that we
borrowed from the mitochondrial matrix
path for B represents an alternative way
to return the oxaloacetate molecule to
the mitochondrial matrix for B involves
the Mallik enzyme M II which uses nadp+
to oxidize malate back to oxaloacetate
in the process nadp+
is reduced to NADPH the biosynthetic
precursor this is one of the two major
ways that a cell produces the NADPH the
NEADS for biosynthesis the other way to
and make NADPH is the pentose phosphate
pathway it may seem kind of useless to
have taken an oxaloacetate and then by
using malate dehydrogenase convert that
oxaloacetate to malate and then convert
the malate back to oxaloacetate but by
doing this series of reactions you are
effectively converting an NADH to an nad
pH nad NADPH is desperately needed for
biosynthesis as we'll see lipid
biosynthesis is very NADPH intensive
let's look at a couple of more details
deafs aloe acetate shown in brackets in
step four B exists on the Mallik enzyme
the enzyme facilitates the
decarboxylation of that molecule
remember oxaloacetate is a beta keto
acid decarboxylation by Malak enzyme at
step four B produces pyruvate now we can
follow the pyruvate via the continuation
of step four B into the mitochondrion
the pyruvate becomes a substrate for
pyruvate carboxylase which we've looked
at before pyruvate carboxylase we'll put
a co2 back into pyruvate and convert it
into oxaloacetate pyruvate carboxylase
is an ATP requiring enzyme hence path 4b
has a finite energy requirement it would
seem as though this might be a problem
nevertheless when a cell is doing
biosynthesis it usually has a lot of
energy around in the form of ATP so this
small investment is a good one in order
to first of all restore the oxaloacetate
balance of the mitochondrion and
secondly keep in mind that 4b also gives
you an NADPH which you need for
biosynthesis anyway
let's summarize this figure at the upper
left we start with glucose and by the
hatched lines that glucose is converted
to citrate in the cytoplasm citrate then
yields an acetyl co a molecule that is
the precursor to fatty acids and
cholesterol step 2 dealt with the
problem of getting oxaloacetate back
into the mitochondrion remember fatty
acid biosynthesis happens in the
cytoplasm we borrowed in oxaloacetate
from the mitochondrion hence we have two
reget it back to
it belongs in the mitochondrial matrix
past 4a and 4b represent alternative
pathways for getting the oxaloacetate
backward belongs
once the oxaloacetate is back in the
mitochondrion then the next molecule of
acetyl co a can come in get converted to
citrate and follow the hatched line path
ultimately resulting in synthesis of
lipids let's turn now to storyboard 26
panel a at this point we have a pool of
acid Co coenzyme a in the cytoplasm it's
now ready to start making a fatty acid
in the carboxylase module I talked about
how asset ile Co a carboxylase is one of
the carboxyl aces took an active form of
co2 and placed it onto the methyl carbon
at the end of the acetyl coenzyme a
molecule the product of the carboxylase
reaction is malonyl coenzyme a this
carboxylase is a biotin containing
enzyme and requires ATP as I've said
earlier Melanie Cohen that make up the
fatty acid the initial fatty acid that
we're going to make is the C 16 fatty
acid palmitate palmitate will be
synthesized entirely on the fatty acid
synthase let's look at panel B fatty
acid synthesis in bacteria is carried
out by a series of enzymes that work as
discrete or independent units
collectively this ensemble of enzymes is
called the fatty acid synthase complex
in mammalian cells all of the enzymatic
activities the same enzymatic activities
are present in a single very long
peptide at this point I want to go over
the chemistry behind each of the
activities in the fatty acid synthase
complex one of the peptides that I
introduced briefly above is called a CP
or a CL carrier protein it contains a
cysteine sulfide role residue that will
attack the carbonyl group of Millenial
co a forming a millennial ACP addict
keep in mind that the product is still a
thio ester with all of the chemical
properties you would find in gas OTO
coenzyme a the enzymatic subunit that
does this chemistry is called ma T or
mat from a lineal acetyl transferase
another domain shown at the bottom of
the fatty acid synthase has a cysteine
residue that attacks the carbonyl group
of acetyl co a this reaction is also
catalyzed by Mat hence in this case the
mat subunit forms an asset Ile thio
ester with the fatty acid synthase at
this point we have a male an eel group
at that let's call it northern domain of
the fatty acid synthase as I've drawn it
and an asset eel group at what I'll call
the southern domain let's look at panel
C at this point the fatty acid synthase
is fully primed that is it is loaded
with a malonyl group and an acetyl group
now we can start doing some chemistry to
join these two groups together the
Millenial group has a beta keto acid
functionality so can easily lose co2 and
generate a nucleophile that will then go
down and attack the carbonyl group of
the acetyl residue that is on the
southern domain of the enzyme this
reaction results in the acetyl group
from the southern domain replacing the
co2 moiety on the northern domain that
is the carbonyl group from the southern
domain ends up covalently attached to
the ch2 group with the box over it in
the northern domain the keto Asil since
synthase that is KS domain of the
protein does this reaction the product
of the reaction shows a beta keto a CL
group attached to the northern domain
keep in mind that the beta keto acyl
group is attached specifically to the
ACL carrier protein the next step is
catalyzed by the keto ACL acp reductase
or KR in this case NADPH will reduce the
keto group that is next to the terminal
carbon forming an alcohol specifically
beta hydroxy ACL a CL carrier protein or
ACP this beta hydroxyl four carbon
compound is now primed for dehydration
by a dehydratase
which removes water to form the trans
Delta to ena wheel acp this molecule is
an alkene with a double bond between the
second and third carbons from the thio
ester let's turn now to storyboard 27
the reaction continues with inna Weil
reductase er which uses a
second molecule of NADPH in order to
saturate the double bond of the ena we
lay CP the product is a beauty real ACP
at this point it should be clear as to
what we've done we've taken 2 SOT Alcoa
molecules and fuse them together in the
process we've done a number of
reductions in the product is a pure
hydrocarbon in this case the four carbon
beuter real coenzyme a in order for the
cycle to repeat itself we have to vacate
the ACP or northern site on fatty acid
synthase in order to make it available
for the next molecule of millennial Co a
to come in that's done by the enzyme or
subunit called translocase which simply
moves the butyl group from the northern
site down to the southern site the
northern self hydral on acp of the fatty
acid synthase is now available to
connect with the next incoming molecule
of malonyl coenzyme a the biosynthetic
cycle will now repeat itself six times
in order to form the sixteen carbon long
hydrocarbon palmitate in the figure it's
shown to attach to the northern site of
the fatty acid synthase let's look back
at the overall synthesis scheme what
you'll see is that the terminal two
carbons that is the two carbons furthest
to the right in the molecule came from
acetyl co a but all the other carbons
originally came from a lineal coenzyme a
the last step in the overall reaction
scheme involves a thio esterase
transferring the thio ester bound
palmitate to a water molecule forming
palmitic acid which is released now
let's turn to storyboard 28 as I
mentioned earlier the default length of
a fatty acid is 16 carbons that is
palmitic acid you could look in the book
for pathways leading to elongation
desaturation and branching of the parent
fatty acid chain I'd like to give you
however a little bit of detail on how
membrane lipids are formed as well as
triacylglycerols
let's look at panel a to make these
higher-order lipids fatty acids will
become connected to a three carbon
glycerol backbone the glycerol backbone
is made from dihydroxyacetone phosphate
which is one of the intermediates in the
glycolytic pathway to make the lipid
backbone dihydroxyacetone phosphate is
reduced by glycerol 3-phosphate
dehydrogenase using na
eh as the cofactor the product of this
reaction is glycerol 3-phosphate NaCl
transferase will then take a fatty acyl
coenzyme a and place it on one of the
hydroxyl groups of the glycerol backbone
to form a mono acyl glyceride phosphate
then as shown in panel B a second fatty
acid group will be placed on the only
available hydroxyl to form a die acyl
glyceride phosphate this is otherwise
known as a membrane phospholipid if the
biosynthetic objective is to make a try
a solicit which is of course our major
storage form of energy then a
phosphatase will come in and hydrolyze
off the phosphate from the 3 carbon of
the diacylglycerol phosphate to form
what's called a diet acyl glycerol then
an acyl transferase as above will place
a third fatty acid onto the glycerol
backbone to form a try a solicitor I
door ta G as I said above this is our
principle storage form of energy